Saturday Night Live on NBC 8:00 Eastern
Time Texas Motor Speedway for the
Genesis 300 Indy car is back and I love
talking to this guy but we're also
talking about Michigan losing the
Colorado on a Hail Mary in 1994 and
that's the worst sporting event that I
can recall and it was on last night on
ESPN and suddenly I want to talk to
Graham Rahal what's up buddy I'm
Goodrich how you doing are you fired up
or what I am I am it's uh it's nice to
be back
you know it's kind of been a weird for
everybody I've got a weird last few
months and for sports and general it's I
mean when that's all when the Rudy
Gobert thing went down it was literally
the day before our season was supposed
to start right and we went from being in
st. Pete in the hotel going racing
tomorrow to cancel grace you know
nothing for three months I mean had this
happened you know in three or four days
later we would have had our first race
in her belt and said you know here we
are and we're getting ready to go
saturday night primetime on NBC it's a
huge opportunity for our sport being
primetime obviously we're sad enough to
have fans in the stands right you know
it's good to get some sports back and
racing teams have been spearheading that
right now and I'm excited to get going
and you wanted six former winners in the
field and it's gonna be all exciting on
that front and but are you in
you're obviously you're in the state of
Texas right now you're calling it from
right now I am NOT I am I am in
Indianapolis right now they're trying to
you know it's a one-day show so
literally we show up tomorrow morning
none of us have tested no no nobody's
driven these cars in four months yes
you're gonna show up tomorrow morning
you're gonna practice for an hour you're
gonna do two laps of qualifying and
you're gonna go race on prime-time at
NBC so you know and this isn't just a
normal race I mean Texas is the most
intense rates of our calendar each and
every year so to throw us out it's like
throwing you to the wolves I mean throw
us out there and this one in particular
is going to be pretty in
it's also the first time the Indy cars
will have a narrow screen so basically
like you know looking like a fighter jet
on the ground a little bubble that goes
over your head it's gonna keep us
protected so again that even hasn't been
proven out right I mean it's never been
in a race yet so yeah again going to the
most intense place of the year it's
gonna be pretty interesting but you know
we're excited to get back get back going
and I think give people whether you're
you listen to this show you're sports
fan period right you know whether you
watch IndyCar racing or not it's a great
opportunity for you to tune in and see
some live sports and Saturday night what
about health protocol and all that stuff
walk me through a grant what do you got
for me we all get yeah so everybody has
to show up a certain amount of hours
before first practice um typically you
know we would show up about an hour
before first practice as a driver in
this case we have to show up a minimum
of three hours early with that you go to
a health screening you do I would I
assume is a swab test obviously
temperature test each team gets charter
bus in on separate buses each team has
been monitoring each other while we've
been working at the race shops and
limited shift so we're pretty aware of
those guys current health situations and
I haven't had anybody that's shown to be
positive whatsoever so you know it's
kind of an interesting period of time
it's certainly going to be slower that
you know to get us into the track and
all the teams into the track but they're
taking their precautions you know like I
said everybody's going to be tested
tomorrow and unfortunately if you pop up
positive whether you're a driver whether
you're anybody you're not going in now
they have limited us
so only allowed 20 crew members per
entry you think that sounds like a lot
it's not you know typically we can have
5060 people go to support our race team
on a weekend right in this case fairly
limited limited enough that a lot of
people spouses aren't going a lot of the
PR staffs aren't going just the you know
needed needed people to run the cars
what about Letterman Letterman is not
but she did call me this weekend
he told me all he said is to grant
heard you're going on riches show make
sure you tell rich how much I like the
[ __ ] and go bucs that's what he told me
to tell you that's odd
that's so odd that that would be his
message good he's just you know I think
pretty pretty locked up right now I know
he's excited to be watching sure
like I said tomorrow night Saturday
night you know a kind of a strange time
for all I'm sure I know so what do you
think Graham Rahal here on the Rich
Eisen show again 8:00 Eastern Time live
racing IndyCar Series returns and then
of all the locations Texas Motor
Speedway up 200 miles an hour or I mean
this is a serious track serious
situation and an exciting return here
and I'll be on NBC at 8:00 Eastern Time
in primetime
what about out on the track do you think
there'll be more caution as you're
driving I mean it takes some time maybe
to get the feel of things and then it'll
just be like normal what do you expect
him Graham well so it's interesting cuz
the race has been shortened from the
normal 248 laps to being 200 so I think
that's gonna breed a little bit more
anxiety into the guys to be hey you know
I if I start 10 I need to make my way to
the front sooner then 248 laughs a lot
of time for things to come and happen
plus 248 laps typically the sun's down
right and by the end of that race and in
this case you know it's 8:00 Eastern
that's seven local turn I don't know
that we're actually ever gonna race
completely in darkness and why that
affects us because when the Sun Goes
Down all the sudden the track gets a lot
more grip you can drive a little bit
more aggressively so on but the other
side of that says I hope I hope that
everybody uses their head because Texas
is also probably the most dangerous
track and go to all year and so you know
throwing everybody out there together
intense already adding in a couple of
rookies that have never even done an
oval race intense you know there's a lot
of question marks that come into play
here but I certainly think people
understand the danger of it people
understand that we're going to a place
that
that is certainly you know been its
heard some guys before and so I think
that they everybody understands you got
to take a little more caution in
particularly like I said with this arrow
screen
we've never raced it it's never been
driven into the evening through sundown
you know as the Sun starts to go down
the glare that that foot typically is
always a problem well we don't know what
it's going to do with the arrow screen
yet so there's a lot of questions you
know that we're gonna find out tomorrow
night live on TV as everybody's watching
which may not be the most ideal way to
do this all right that is what we're
gonna do and be fun we explain to people
what that screen is and who may not know
Graham so it's uh it's a pretty cool new
piece of technology if you look at any
cars on my dad drove back in the 80s 90s
you know the cars today are far safer
than they were at that time having said
that this is probably the largest
improvement in safety since I've been
around which is you know we use
literally f-16 f-18 fighter jet canopy
reshaped so this is a ballistic piece of
it's a composite glass basically that
can take a which is this is an important
piece of information rich it can take
like a 20-pound frozen turkey at 250
miles an hour's if that that's really
really important Oh like like you're
gonna be facing frozen turkeys every day
but that is actually the test that they
utilize in the fighter jets as well and
so this is a piece that is now in front
of the driver's head it wraps around
mounts to where the roll bar is this
this piece would have honestly that we
lost the driver in 2015
Justin Wilson a very important guy in my
life we lost him at Pocono I think had
we had this piece Justin Wilson still be
with us so this is a huge improvement to
the head and neck and brain safety for
drivers it's the first open-wheel car in
the world to have this sort of cockpit
you know and so it's it's you know
meaning IndyCar Formula One we're the
first
able to do it to this sort of level and
so we're excited about that PPG actually
makes a glass same company that makes a
glass with a fighter jet so this is it's
a pretty advanced piece we've had to
work on the shape for the glare cuz
clearly in an Indy car when you're
turning a lot fighter jets are
necessarily turning on banking like we
are and so it's important that we get
all the distortion out of it and stuff
but it's been really good it's been huge
you know groundbreaking changes and
developments and the safety of of open
little cars and we're looking forward to
giving it a shot
me too Graham before I let you go the
conversation that we've been having
today is based on the fact that last
night ESPN had the audacity to re air
the Colorado Michigan 1994 contest at
the big house and I had to relive it and
we're just talking about what people's
worst sports losses of their fandom was
and yours has to be if I'm not mistaken
the 2002 BCS National Championship game
where you lost to Miami oh no I'm sorry
you got bailed out by an outrageous flag
at the end they're allowing you to score
a game tire and eventually win a tainted
championship for trestle I mean you know
so I'm wondering if that's if that's the
one Graham I think for me yeah has to be
the Purdue game just a couple years ago
because I great Graham come on come on
it was terrible it was so cold we were
supposed to dominate and we got I mean
that's a regular-season game you mean it
was dumped by the way just for your own
knowledge out of respect to you I do
have the Ohio State sort of semi racing
helmet that you brought here on the show
that has been signed by many Ohio State
football players and graduates who are
proud to sign this helmet for the show
you cannot say a regular-season game at
Purdue
we're blown out when you were come on no
no I know Michigan is you know but look
okay so I even texted you I was texting
you during this game yes a Clemson game
last year still stings
I mean first first half just gone
then you get a couple questionable calls
Shawn Wade obviously then you got to
fumble that still stings I'm not I don't
think you're gonna we're gonna go beat
LSU but I mean Ohio State had a great
chance
so all I'm hoping is that you know we
get back out here we get some college
football because you know once racing
comes to an end I mean you know me I
blow you up on every Saturday yeah right
now I'm reading I'm reading the text
exchange I just call it up on my phone
you text me you agree with targeting how
do you call targeting when the player
ducks into it good point I wrote back it
looked like football in the replay your
guy lowered his head that's 15 yards in
NFL get your head to either side of
Lawrence's body and square up oh and
chase young necktie him you wrote back
something I can't repeat it's BS and the
refs know it ejecting weight really
hurts
OSU and then I tweeted back we ivory
tweeted back the Seinfeld popcorn eating
jiff that's a shame so that was our
exchange you get rid of Sean Wade and
all of a sudden that became a without
his speed in the middle you got a whole
different ballgame yeah you wrote back
lol you need to be a pro Big Ten guy
here I wrote that need is such a strong
word Graham right there so you can even
peg one huh
come on now come on well you were
growing up in Ohio State wasn't winning
squat that's when John Cooper was there
so wasn't there one that yeah you know
it's not the only sporting but you know
true I mean honest it up for me oh you
know at that time David Letterman is a
guy who's helped in my whole career it's
very difficult for you to peg it but I
understand Graham life's tough what are
you I'm telling you the Clemson loss
still stings
okay still it's still things I will get
me fired up just I'm gonna go out there
and be on a tear demonic
when you're standing next to the trophy
you thank me please all right Graham
real quick Graham real quick as an Ohio
State fan start bench cut which of these
Michigan losses makes you happiest the
Westbrook Hail Mary Kordell Stewart Hail
Mary the loss to Appalachian State or
the walk-off punt fumble snap to
Michigan State so you see the start
start the one that makes you happiest I
think appstate is definitely a pretty
pretty good story although according to
her he goes on to play for Pittsburgh
right and becomes a huge customer of our
car dealership so I he treated the REA
Hall family well so I'll take all right
very good
anytime Michigan loses I'm it takes me
everything I can not to text rich and
you know it's my pleasure but you know
Graham it's my pleasure drip his clarity
sometimes I gotta be nice it is my
pleasure to say we're out of time Graham
I look forward to seeing you race good
luck and do thank me when you win
tomorrow because I got the juices
flowing okay he's safe I that's Graham
Rahal check out again the IndyCar Series
return tomorrow night on NBC Saturday
8:00 Eastern Time
who cares what Graham Rahal face hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here